your influence has got to be crazy
because like you you are you mentioned
andre earlier
yeah you know when you listen to your
music you could hear some sugar-free
[ __ ] the freestyle were about to drop i
i heard some reminisce of some of that
you know what i'm saying
definitely gonna hear the west coast um
talk about your influences man
um my influences always change if that
made any sense like
i've never listened to jay-z until 2020.
you know what i'm saying
really i never we know i know his
records
but you never like tapped in never like
actually really i know you're right i
know word for word couple songs but i
don't know i hear what you said no the
jay-z that you know
right right right right right right
right now i'm saying i know nipsey of
course it's just played to me all the
time
from the west coast i know 40 it's
played to me all the time it's familiar
music but
i started venturing on so this this year
i went back
into some oldies in my catalog that i
used to listen to that i forgot about
like the usher's confession album
50 cent get richer diet trying um
even the pleasure plea album you know
hey pleasure pee
man pleasure pleasure peter p5 pretty
ricky had a run man you know what i'm
saying t-fly
t-fly he fly another guy who's out of
out of
la who i i really hoped would have been
bigger but he definitely kicked down
some like sonic
sonic doors for a lot of people like he
was doing a lot of [ __ ] before live
i know you know a rider when you see it
yeah no he's an alien for sure for sure